[Musique]
si jamais un jour ton vieux beau petit
passe par dessus la barrière
[Musique]
il voudrait que sa petite bille qui
était continue dans le monde heureux
mais qu'à poursuivre ce qu'on a bossé
tous les deux ensemble
[Applaudissements]
un diamant brut
j'ai presque mon enquête publique avant
mettre tout le monde à terre mais si
maintenant un moment que nous attendons
tous avec impatience et la révélation
québec de piano voici
j'étais grand rêve pour elle et je le
sais que votre retraite faut que voie
aux choses qui sortent de vous du pont
oui il faut pas se cacher question
dansions mieux quand même
ce trafic à effectuer
tu veux
que
foot gay tombeur d'aboud dchir que lui
c'est pareil j'avais pas compris que
pour ma petite princesse seul prince qui
lui faut prévient bruno bronze et k3 62
fois et demi son âge et qui deux fois
divorcé il ya beau avoir le monde entier
dans la salle c'est pour lui que je
chante pas mal et puis accor cette folie
là on va pas la faire car moi qu'un
droit payet yeux et dis moi que tu aimes
pas
[Musique]
mardi
le sang
[Musique]